un líder valiente un padre único no
estas son algunas de las palabras que se
utilizan para recordar a desmond tutu
tras la muerte del arzobispo el domingo
los sudafricanos expresaron su tristeza
por la pérdida del hombre apodado la
brújula moral del país algunos de los
dolientes visitaron su casa en soweto
mientras que otros se reunieron frente a
su antigua parroquia en ciudad del cabo
es realmente muy triste y creo que no
sólo para sudáfrica sino para áfrica
como continente hemos perdido un gran
icono continente el presidente
sudafricano cyril ramaphosa acudió a
twitter para presentar sus respetos
desmon tutú fue un patriota sin igual un
líder de principios y pragmatismo que
dio sentido a la visión bíblica de que
la fe sin obras está muerta oramos para
que el alma del arzobispo tutú descanse
en paz pero que su espíritu sea el
centinela del futuro de nuestra nación
compañero de lucha de nelson mandela su
fundación emitió un comunicado era un
ser humano extraordinario un pensador un
líder un pastor nuestros pensamientos
están con su familia y amigos en este
momento tan difícil
los líderes mundiales también
reconocieron los considerables logros de
tuto estoy profundamente entristecido
por escuchar de la muerte del arzobispo
desmond tutu él fue una figura crítica
en la lucha contra el apartheid y la
lucha para crear una nueva sudáfrica
será recordado por su espíritu de
liderazgo y su incontenible buen humor
ganador del premio nobel de paz en 1984
desmond tutu dedicó su vida a los
derechos humanos ya la igualdad de los
pueblos su lucha por el fin del
apartheid y la reconciliación
sudafricana será recordada
la iglesia anglicana se encargará de
planificar el funeral de tutu y otros
servicios conmemorativos que se
celebrarán de acuerdo con las
restricciones por corona vigor